yo what's going on guys crispy flakes
here of bleacher reports for today's
video we are checking out off-season
trade ideas for the nba's most hopeless
team so let me know in the comment
section below if you are the fan of a
team that's just not going to make the
playoffs or might barely make the
playing tournament uh let me know a
trade that realistically you would like
to see this nba all season i know some
of our fan bases out there are already
kind of thinking about the future who we
can draft and trade for and all that
good stuff man so let's go ahead and get
going on this and see which trades are
listed uh the first thing we have is the
detroit pistons and this is going to be
a trade of kevin herner and deandre
hunter in exchange for jeremy grant so
from a pistons fan standpoint i actually
really like this i mean kevin herter is
a six seven guard that can knock down
the three-point shot at 40 which would
be nice in the backcourt with either
kate cunningham or killian hayes at any
given moment uh then deandre hunter has
had a bit of injury history but i will
say when he does play he's just a really
good all-around player and i really
think that uh deandre hunter can become
like a
18.5 rebound five assists type of guy
with some decent defense out there too
um and then with jeremy grant going over
to the hawks you get more of like the
sure thing borderline all-star caliber
player if that were to happen i would
see probably a guy like john collins
being traded away uh to try to get
somebody at that two spot next to trey
young in the backcourt maybe a defensive
oriented type of guard three type of
guard and everything like that but
overall um i do like the trade i don't
think it's bad for either side depending
on the hawks making some moves to uh
best you know utilize the fit their team
and everything uh next up we have the
houston rocket so here we got th t in a
first round pick oh thc russell
westbrook and a first round pick in
exchange for john wall air gordon
harvest and honest this should have
happened to the trade online i don't
really know what the hiccup was with it
um i think from the houston rockets
standpoint you know not only do you get
a pick out of it but you also get a good
young player in thc at least potentially
and then russell westbrook would be the
same case as john wall where he either
doesn't play
or maybe you could buy him out now in
this case the rockets could just buy out
john wall but in this case you get a
bought out contract and russell
westbrook but you still get some assets
back in it and the lakers uh hopefully
fix some of their issues i mean even if
like john wall got injured he didn't
play for the lakers like eric gordon
would help out this lakers team a lot
better right now than what russell
westbrook's doing so uh yeah i think
it's a w trade for both sides uh next up
we got the indiana pacers this is gonna
be al horford and a second round pick in
exchange for buddy healed so this is
simply for the indiana pacers to get out
of buddy heals contract the way he's
actually been playing has been really
solid uh would definitely help a team
like the boston celtics right now if i'm
being honest though i do think
the way he's been playing i i think the
pacers could get a bit of a better haul
out of it i guess it's just like what's
the motivation behind it um and i think
motivation would be simply to you know
free up some cap space and build around
tyrese halibut in going forward
um next up we do have the new york
knicks and the orlando magic and this is
going to be a trade of markelle fultz in
exchange for cam reddish and kemba
walker now if the magic were to trade
for kemba walker he would probably get
bought out so essentially it's markelle
fultz for cam reddish which uh i think
makes sense for both sides i think that
the knicks really do need their point
guard of the future now marco foles you
know elephant in the room he does have
injury history but when he does play man
like if you checked him out before he
got injured with the magic um he was ex
like i'm like an absolute tear i'm not
saying he's worthy of like
or playing up with like that top three
pick or whatnot but uh
he's really good man like i like markup
volkswagen i think he's got a future
with um you know a team like the new
york knicks
on the magic i mean i like him over
there but i think jalen suggs is the man
like jalen suggs needs to be the point
guard of that squad over there and it's
just a log game over there the magic
getting somebody like cam reddish who
could develop to be a paul george type
player in my opinion i really see that
in his play style um i think it makes
100 for both sides man and uh it's just
you know two guys that haven't
become anything quite yet but you see
the greatness potential based off of
some of their past performances
uh next we do have the okc thunder and
this is going to be zion williamson in
exchange for darius baisley a 20 22
first round pick a 20 23 first round
pick and a 2024 first round pick
okay so
we know that zion has not been the most
motivated to get into shape a big part
of that could be because of his injuries
but also we know that as far as him
being on the pelicans i don't think it
was like his first choice and if i'm be
quite honest i don't know if the okc
thunder would be his second choice as
far as like teams to go to um when he
does become a free agent and everything
like that
i'm afraid of the thunder giving up all
these assets and then just zion leaving
eventually but with that being said a
team of zion shaco's alexander and josh
getty like that is super intriguing um
but also in the case of the pelicans you
know again darius baisley could be a
three level scorer you get some picks
out of it um assuming that we know zion
doesn't want to be
on the pelicans i really think that uh
that would become more vocalized and in
a way it kind of has with his family has
been saying things um if zion were to go
on the market though i think that
just
i don't i don't think this would be
enough i think that there would be a lot
of big market teams that would throw a
lot more of the pelicans away to even
have a chance at zion to convincing him
to stay with the team in the long term
um if i'm the pelicans i definitely
would want either shea or josh giddy
back and uh
yeah just like i mean i think i feel
like everything's just not enough the
traffics and everything but at the same
time too i've always been like intrigued
by the idea of
how many like players could the thunder
really get if they traded all their
draft picks away you know like they got
so many pick assets and everything like
could they just build a super team by
trading all those away uh within the
next few years or so um zion definitely
would not be a bad start
and then for the final trade right here
we do have kelly ubre uh to the
sacramento kings in exchange for sean
holmes so by doing this you know rashawn
homes is a good quality starting center
um but the good thing about this too is
like mantra's hero his contract i
believe is expiring so he's could very
well just not stay at the charlotte
hornets this season or he could sign
with him but even if he does choose to
resign we know that mantras does better
in a backup role it's just kind of what
he's used to so in this case you know
mason plumlee's not been a great player
for the charlotte hornets so you get
sean holmes as your full-time starter
and uh you know you can have montrez
going and substitute for him um during
the course of the game i think that
rotation uh works out nicely for the
next few seasons and then ubrae you know
you get a nice athletic player next to
sabonis over on that king squad to run
up and down the court with uh you know
darren fox and likes the players like
that uh so overall yeah i think this is
a good solid trade that gives both teams
um a little bit of what they need in
this moment i think a lot of these
trades represent that just like good
moves that just get teams in the right
direction so that's all we have for this
video uh let me know in the comment
section what you think about these
trades thank you all so much for
watching and peace out my friends